also mich interessiert vor allem
momentan der demografische Wandel ja
durch die vielen durch die omni-krise
die wir momentan haben es brennt ja
irgendwie an jeder Ecke vergessen wir
das natürlich auch eine Wirtschaft in
Zukunft gibt und die müssen wir uns
kümmern denn die ist relativ klar zu
prognostizieren also wenn man sich die
Altersverteilung in Deutschland oder den
meisten westlichen Ländern anschaut dann
sieht man relativ schnell wir haben
ziemlich viele Leute die jetzt langsam
ins Pensionsalter kommt wohl verdient
das Blöde ist nur wir haben wenn man so
möchte über spitz gesagt nicht genug
Nachschub also wir haben schlichtunter
greifen nicht mehr genug junge warme
Körper um all die Position die frei
werden zu füllen und dann müssen wir
etwas einfallen lassen denn der Vorteil
den wir jetzt momentan haben ist wir
sind jetzt in einem Arbeitnehmermarkt
zum ersten Mal ja also die Arbeitnehmer
können jetzt auf einmal andere
Forderungen an Unternehmen stellenweise
jetzt sehr sehr dringend gebraucht sind
das ist anders wenn man einen großen
Überfluss an Arbeitskräften hat aber es
gibt noch ein paar andere Hebel die wir
bedienen können und die finde ich vor
allem sehr spannend wir haben heute
schon gehabt das Thema Automatisierung
Digitalisierung künstliche Intelligenz
da tut sich einiges da werden viele
Berufe auch obsolet werden aber auch wie
können wir mehr
Frauen in Beschäftigung bringen in
Deutschland desto vor allem mit den
europäischen Ländern ein großes Thema
also es gibt die Hebel und die müssen
wir jetzt in Bewegung bringen weil sonst
verlieren wir halt ein Attraktivität als
Wirtschaftsstandort und ich glaube eine
Sache die wir doch sehr gerne mögen ist
dann erfolgreiche Wirtschaft in
Deutschland also es ist so eine Sache
die wir ganz gerne wollen welche Hebel
müssen wir also in Bewegung setzen
lassen uns einmal kurz bei der jungen
Generation bleiben werden die
überstrapaziert oder sind sie nicht
genug
leistungsstarken Generation sagt ja ihr
kennt gar nicht mehr lehrjahre sind
Herrenjahre und die neue Generation sagt
ja Entschuldigung wir stellen uns
arbeiten ganz anders vor wo liegt die
Wahrheit
sie ist natürlich immer ein bisschen
komplexe die gute alte Wahrheit ist es
vor allem so dass die jüngeren
Generation sich das immer anhören müssen
also jeder egal welcher Generation hier
am Tisch das hat die Eltern Generation
schon mal über euch gesagt das ist so
das kann man ein bisschen die Antike
zurückverfolgen auch dieses Thema keiner
will mehr arbeiten niemand ist mehr
leistungsfähig das kann man
zurückverfolgen es wurde jedes Jahr
gedruckt seitdem es Zeitung gibt also es
ist ein Thema das kommt immer wieder es
stimmt auch nicht ja was allerdings
bestimmt ist dass ich die Arbeitswelt
langsam verändert vor allem die jüngeren
Generation komme jetzt langsam im Berufe
rein die doch eher digital geprägt sind
deswegen wollen ja auch viele
Unternehmen sehen und da treffen sie
dann aber auf Arbeitsstrukturen die
natürlich in Deutschland sehr
industriell geprägt sind ja das ist ja
auch zu Recht so in Deutschland kann
Industrie verdammt gut das haben sich
historisch schon ein paar mal bewiesen
nun ist aber die Frage wie wandelt man
und ich glaube das ist uns allen klar
wir stehen hier von dem Umbruch
industriezeitleiter ins Information
und die klassischen alten Arbeitsmodelle
die sehr auf abgesessener Zeit passiert
sind und das hat der BGH ja in also in
Deutschland oder auch in Europa
natürlich bestätigt
Vertrauensarbeitszeit das war eine Zeit
lang Thema es gibt nichts man wird dafür
bezahlt wie Stunden
leistet und die jüngere Generation steht
natürlich vor einer Situation wo wenn
sie den Beruf einsteigt und mal zwei
Drittel aus Einkommen zu Fixkosten
ausgeben muss sich deswegen nicht
wirklich etwas zusammen sparen kann und
dann die ganze Zeit noch hören muss das
liegt daran dass du zu faul bist und
nicht dass die ökonomische Lage
mittlerweile alles so ist und das hat
natürlich zu großen Kränkungen geführt
und die spürt man jetzt ein bisschen
zwischen den Generationen ich glaube
wenn wir mal ein bisschen loslösen
können von diesen klassischen
Arbeitsmodellen die immer nur mit
abgesessener Zeit und Kontrolle
zusammenhängen und endlich verdammt noch
mal nach Leistungen gehen ich habe ja
mal gehört leistung soll sich auch
irgendwann mal lohnen dann würde man
glaube ich merken dass die Jungen auf
einmal sehr sehr leistungsfähig und sehr
motiviert sind sie haben nur keinen Bock
in einer alten Arbeitswelt fest zu
hängen und nur sozusagen zur
kontrollbefriedigung ihrer Chef dort zu
sein das ist glaube ich die Konflikte
Ebene bei der wir gerade sind jung
wollen dürfen aber nicht sagt
ja ich glaube tatsächlich ist ein Wandel
ist ein Evolution auf dem Arbeitsprozess
also auch durch Corona hat mir auf
einmal Homeoffice hat er dann auch ganz
gut funktioniert und ich glaube
tatsächlich also man muss in Zukunft
anders arbeiten ist doch egal ob der
jetzt zu Hause sitzt beim Arbeitsplatz
oder hier bei viertel nach acht und
schreibt sein Text oder macht seine
Aufgaben ja ähm hauptsache das Ergebnis
stimmt ich würde wirklich
ergebnisorientiert belassen und wo man
arbeiten möchte ist doch völlig egal da
müssen tatsächlich ein Wandel in die
kreieren weil das alte mit der
Stempeluhr das ist vorbei keiner will
kontrolliert werden es gibt ein schönes
Zitat von Goethe der gesagt hat
Vertrauen veredelt den Menschen ewige
Bevormundung hemmt sein Reifen und es
tatsächlich um überhaupt nicht die
besten Ideen auf dem Klo
aber alle Unternehmen Sebastian auch die
Leute wieder zurückgeholt aus dem
Homeoffice auch die großen IT-Riesen
beispielsweise haben gesagt kommt wieder
zurück offenbar hat man damit nicht so
gute Erfahrungen gemacht offenbar will
man genau das was er hat nämlich weiter
den Blick darauf haben was und wie viele
Leute arbeiten ja das kommt schon sehr
darauf an das glaube ich je nach Branche
auch ganz unterschiedlich teilweise
eröffnet das ja auch Möglichkeiten dass
man sagt den Job hat sich jemand in
Indien machen ne das ist vielleicht dann
auch billiger das wird natürlich auch
wieder Arbeit ausgelagert kann auch ein
Problem sein also aber ein Handwerkern
also in Stuttgart
Arbeiten es wird niemals funktionieren
ja also dahin gehen müssen wir schon ein
bisschen gucken welche Porsche wir uns
annehmen aber das ist ja auch das schöne
dass dadurch ganz klar wird wo geht's
mit Digitalisierung und wo auch nicht
also es gibt ja momentan also für die
Beispiele Installateur Handwerker und so
weiter fallen richtiges Bamberg weil sie
auf einmal sehr sehr dringend gebraucht
sind man muss auch sagen das muss man
ganz ehrlich betonen man hatte jüngeren
Generation immer gesagt du brauchst
jetzt eine gute Ausbildung weil sonst
musst du einen dieser Berufe machen und
auf einmal sind das die Berufe die aber
alle wollen ja also das Handwerk ja ganz
oft ganz oft gibt's halt die Zukunft auf
deine Kombination aus dem alten was Sinn
macht und dem neuen was gut ist und das
sieht man ja auch dass diese Berufe
natürlich sehr sehr viel Sinn gemacht
haben und ich möchte vielleicht auch
noch gerade dieses Thema Vertrauen das
wird immer gepredigt ich bin ja viele
bei Unternehmen unterwegs sondern der
Wirtschaft und dann wird immer groß
gesagt ja ja bei uns im Unternehmen ist
Vertrauen ganz ganz wichtig
genau und wenn man dann drei Bier in die
rein kippt dann sagen die immer sofort
der Vertrauen ist gute erwachsen aber
Kontrolle ist schon noch besser also das
ist ein das ist natürlich ich nehme das
auch nicht böse die sind ja aufgewachsen
in einer Welt und sehr erfolgreich damit
gefahren in der Industrialisierung mit
diesen arbeitskonzepten und fühlen sich
jetzt natürlich gekränkt wenn ihre
Führungsrolle hinterfragt wird es ist ja
verständlich aber gerade Deutschland
muss mit dem großen Wohlstand den wir
haben darauf setzen dass man das jetzt
nutzt um diesen Übergang den man ja ein
bisschen verpennt hat jetzt aufzuholen
und das das ist hauptsächlich eine
filmkulturelle Frage glaube ich nicht so
sehr eine der Technologie und des
Budgets weil das Hammer in Deutschland
eigentlich aber ehrlicherweise
Vertrauensarbeitszeit schön und gut und
so weiter muss ja sagen sowas wie die 40
Stunden Woche ist schon auch eine
soziale Errungenschaften
erkämpft wurden wenn das jetzt
aufgeweicht wird für das auch schon
wieder wieso aber ich finde das spricht
der spricht ja nichts dagegen es gibt ja
auch Berufe die Bereitschaftsdienste
brauchen die Zeit als die Indikation
haben ja aber es gibt vermehrt Berufe
die das nicht haben und das muss man
anerkennen Zeit abgesessene Zeit ist
super Indikator wenn man das breit über
alle Berufe Flächen will aber das
funktioniert halt immer weniger ja
Berufe werden kleinteilige individueller
flexibler digitaler und das muss man
dementsprechend auch einfach anpassen
und ja für den zustimmen die
Errungenschaft von 60 auf 48 auf 40
Stunden war fantastisch oder dieses
Papier gehört sonntags mir oder samstags
ja in vielen Berufen ist diese
Flexibilität natürlich möglich in
anderen Berufen halten wir fest geht das
überhaupt nicht da wird man weiter in
Schichten arbeiten müssen muss man da
sein muss man präsent sein und andere
Möglichkeiten gibt es da vermutlich